I don't want to think of cruise and uh
I think Henry saludos is astonishing and
every time he fights he has a new
texture and better you see those leg
kicks like every time that guy fights
and I think that comes from being the I
think he's the youngest gold medalist
ever in wrestling Lisa yeah that's
incredible
I mean to be winning gold medal in in
wrestling is so ridiculous it's so
ridiculous took four years off and and I
think this is a guy who listens he was
11 years old has been watching the human
body move younger than that yep and he's
been watching how the human body moves
and he's got his learning curve his his
learning curve is crazy high his fight
IQ just because he's been doing it so
long and I think also he's just that
kind of guy it's also called insane
talent he's a [ __ ] amazing athlete
actually and I think and then you know
it was do you think it was stopped too
soon because Dominick Cruz was on his
way up that's a fair argument it's fair
I always cut side on if they're heavier
guys I would say stop it early yes like
within Ghana as soon as that dudes light
stuff jump the [ __ ] yes with Bantam
weights and the lightweights and the 25
hours and the fly weights that I mean
you know I go on it's not like they're
gonna hurt each other and also there's
two seconds left in the round
it's a world champion fight you could
let it go and he was working I forgot
about that and he was working out he was
he was here's here's my raps kinda going
hard in the paint on social media is it
hmm he is what he's mostly a video
Dominick like you know when he got hit
with the knee goes oh I'm sorry strength
prevent more CT I think he's right I
personally I think the stoppage is
warranted and here's the other reason I
think so I think that that eda Peterson
if it's not that if it's not that
finishes usually pretty legit he's
[ __ ] if you look at Dominic Cruz's
face and you're there and I watched him
he took five unanswered punches 1111
irons punches stop the fight
in my opinion I think it's better to err
on the side of caution
maybe this this time it wasn't 9 times
out of 10 rather you're on toss right
nine times that light weights and world
champ ship fight and stomp Cruz I
understand but yeah he generally not
you're right
times out Timmy did the right try he's
trying to protect the fighter and I
would never you know Dominick Cruz is
always gonna be a work about him no this
is a fake account just type in his did
you type in his name yeah that's it
right there we gotta go to Twitter he's
kind of it's going pretty hard in the
paint that's it keep it there is look so
he looks like he was a fighter himself I
mean looked me in the morning after a
night of drinking smoking and like it's
a picture yeah found the Cruz that's
price ran upon they put a Tom Cruise I
thought by stopping the fight I stop you
from getting CT but I guess not I
understand
I don't though I I don't want you
exactly coming zombie coming up around
want that out of my rest I have want
that personal engagement with the
fighters hmm came as if judges were like
it's over yeah that's it it's
unprofessional it is it's a lot
unprofessional
he's he's being he's being personal as
opposed to just explain his role of his
philosophy see when he put me in the
morning after night drinking and smoking
in the post picture of him yeah that's
that's district ruse it's disrespectful
yeah and has he fought in the UFC a
know-it-all so compromises his ability
now if he's if he's roughing another
foot I went one of it because I'm gonna
God if I lose out I got him posting and
[ __ ] like wait go back go back go back
it says Dominick Cruz near see post
fight show claims referee Keith here
smelled like alcohol and cigarettes
during his fight said he wanted to have
referee changed when he stopped in the
cage wow I step in the gate wow that's
weird
yeah I don't think this Keith Peterson's
do himself any favors by trolling
adjusting I mean uh Dominick Cruz no
it's gonna but the other thing I was
gonna say is I think that Henry wins
that fight regardless yes so was it
looking great for him no so let's take
that into account too
I mean I think Dominick was having a
really hard time with those [ __ ] leg
kicks yeah and it didn't look like the
Adamic that were used to either it
looked like you know maybe he was
throwing jabs and kind of
jabs and things like that but I don't
think that was gonna do much to any suit
I'm not worried about that more his
footwork he was that ass on the you know
yeah I can't see that I don't know I
don't I can't see that I'm not aware I'm
hopefully it went well
unbelievable pacing for buys you just
never know easy rise by any of them like
Trump were you surprised by any of the
outcomes did you have Dominick Cruz
winning that fight I thought if version
of Dominick Cruz that were used to shut
up he could be so who don't can you go
to the 45 division for a sec I want to
just know it what do you want I want to
just fantasize about interesting who to
chop it up to 45 oh well he's retired
well if the check is big enough he's not
retired right when he I loved what he
said so what so when he came on my show
food-truck diary watch it when we're off
here I'm going through all these
matchups here's Bubba but I'm probably
retire hey what he was probably one more
I'm done he was I'm sick of this [ __ ]
they don't pay me enough I have other
stuff going on
Wow and I think I didn't say I that's
not my bit now that's a lie can't talk
about it well I went really is yeah
I have no argument that makes sense I'm
gold medalist 125 champ 135 champ
defended alright yeah cool dude is he
too small for Brown Ortega max Holloway
those upbeats a beat six to talk about
like my mother guy retired right so
let's go through Tom oh yeah he's said
he's been retired then they're not
paying money and now fight bigger guys
that's a that's yeah he has trouble
making 35 no yeah he said he said it's
tough it's a it's a sock suit was tiny
yeah tiny he thrives at thirty bucks you
know smaller he was the dumb accrues hey
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]